there's a lot in this question and
there's a lot of language which has a
lot of implications for all this stuff
okay so we're going to unpack it
together and then you're going to have a
shot at going on it on your own okay so
if you want you can write down
underneath all of your table and stuff
like that maybe you can write example
and we're having you look at a cricket
ball that gets thrown vertically upwards
so ball in hand we just throw it
straight in the air because you want to
catch it yourself I guess and then they
give you a model remember all that stuff
we were talking about with optimization
before so here's a model of the height X
in meters at time T seconds that stuff's
really important so I'm gonna write it
down right now but X is in meters and
then T is in seconds
well compress it spec so this tells us
how displacement and time are related to
each other so let's go ahead and write
that down x equals 20 t minus 5t squared
so if you know the time I can tell you
the displacement after some number of
seconds I can tell you where the ball
should be up in the air okay all right
so now let's start to unpack like what
is this question asking of us it says
find V velocity and a acceleration as
functions of T of time okay why don't we
do that before we get to the second half
of the question because we can already
just start on that right away
okay velocity is our first derivative
okay so I'm going to write V equals I'll
even just to get it cemented in my brain
for this early point in time it's DX on
DT so there's X can you help me
differentiate with respect to T what am
I gonna get 20 fantastic take away 10 T
excellent so I've differentiated whether
take the time once there's my um there's
my velocity function as requested and
then to do the next part to get to
acceleration I just need to take that
guy and differentiate again just like
you have been with your first driven in
second when it has nothing to do with
this motion situation so this is DV on
DT just the line above and you guys can
go ahead and tell me
whatever it is it's just -10 cool
welcome go to sit mmm all right so these
are the first things I have a look at
the rest of the question it says show
that the ball is always accelerating
downwards now remember I said to you
before that direction matters in all of
these things right so if you look at the
acceleration equation right here maybe I
should use some cars to separate things
out right here's velocity and then
here's acceleration
what does downwards mean in this
situation or maybe a better way to ask
it is what about this equation signifies
down can anyone tell me sir yeah max
okay great so that negative right there
indicates down now how do I know that
look back at the original question it
says a cricket balls thrown vertically
upwards its height its height is X right
and height is an upward measurement okay
we could just as easily say you know the
measurement downward is positive if say
you were like digging you're like a
submarine and like I the only thing that
matters to me is down so therefore I
might make that my positive numbers
rather than just have negatives
everywhere but in my situation they said
height height is measured upwards so
negative is measured downwards so we can
go and we can use some words here to say
since a is less than zero right
acceleration is always downward
okay and we've been emphasizing the
importance of words this whole topic and
this is one of those cases where you
cannot avoid using some verbal language
to explain what's going on okay now the
next bit I'm gonna pause from it and let
you have a go at this because they're
asking us to now sketch we've got one
two three equations and they'd like us
to draw them now you're gonna get pretty
busy on these diagrams so canals should
draw three separate axes they don't have
to be enormous because luckily for you
this is a fairly easy function that
we're starting off with okay I think you
all know roughly what this is supposed
to look like I'll give you a few minutes
to get a head start on me for those of
you just arrived you may like to go a
picture of this because I'm about to get
rid of it because we'll need some space
but for the rest of you draw those
graphs and call me over once you finish
so that I can have a look and see when
you're at the the right spot
what you can see I've done is I've drawn
myself three sets of axes and I have the
distinct advantage of having already
done this question so I kind of know
where my axes are going to head and you
know if you just sort of drew general
axes like this there's nothing wrong
with that but you're very rapidly going
to see that not all off your normal
corner axis will be relevant to the
question okay so for example let's think
about this guy here the displacement
function let's go one step at a time
okay x equals 20 t minus 5t squared so
hopefully you already recognize
generally what kind of shape that's
going to be it's going to be a parabola
and it's not just any parabola
it's a concave down parabola because the
T squared which is the important part
it's got a negative coefficient okay so
it's gonna be something like this okay
you can see and if you didn't do this
it's okay but it just is easier for my
brain anyway III factorized because
factorizing a quadratic helps you find
roots real easy and you kind of need to
know where roots are in order to draw
the thing okay have a look at this i
factorized it here's one factor here's
the other each one tells you were root
five teen what is that factor tell you
where's the root for that it's T equals
zero right what about this one here T
equals four okay now I hope you hear I'm
emphasizing that the Ritter T equals
something and T equals something else
remember it's which is time right so our
horizontal axis is no longer
our x-axis it's our time axis um if you
want the language for that the technical
language it's our independent variable
whereas displacement it depends on time
so it's our dependent variable okay
which we tend to put vertically so now I
know I've got an intercept at 0 and I've
got an intercept I'm just gonna call
that 4 so I'm just gonna mark it in 0 4
you already told me it's a concave down
parabola right
so I'm guessing looks something like
this ok now hopefully you've got
something somewhat like that on your
page or I'll highlight some things that
are really important here ok when you
have a look at this picture the graph
we've done it sort of looks like
someone's standing at the origin and
then like throwing the ball like so
someone off in the distance and then you
know they're standing over here and then
they catch it right but this is not what
the situation represents or it's not
what the graph represents tell me where
the ball has been thrown look back at
the question the Bolden's thrown
straight up right so even though this
graph makes it look like there's some
horizontal motion there is no horizontal
motion this is not like physically going
left to right this is thin things over
time as time progresses right so in fact
the ball is going straight up and down
but what you're looking at is where is
the ball at particular slices of time
particular instances of time okay that's
what it looks like 0 to 4 um there's my
X there's no time let's see if we can do
a velocity graph our velocity time graph
we differentiate it we got 20 minus 10t
kind of graph has that look like it's a
straight line can you tell me any more
about it ok it's gonna have an intercept
at 20 that's good and then what else can
tell me that I've got a gradient that's
decreasing very good and it's just a
straight line so it goes like that ok it
has an intercept right where's that
intercept at - yeah
and that's the whole varsity graph it's
done okay last one acceleration and
please keep in mind write a kind of
functions like your y-axis right so this
could be you could read this as y equals
negative 10 except that it's an
acceleration access so what kind of line
is this
we know it's a straight line like the
previous one but it's not just straight
it's it's a horizontal wine I know
that's sneaky like it's tempting to
these vertical is a horizontal because
they're so used to seeing X's or Y's
right but that's why you have to label
your axes very carefully
that's your vertical axis so your
vertical values are always going to be
equal to negative 10 okay all right now
let me see how well I've done okay I've
tried my best I want you to notice that
on the ends of all of my graphs all
three of my graphs I haven't put errors
and maybe you haven't put arrows either
maybe you just kind of draw a line and
you're like I just left it but it's
important that I didn't do arrows
because I wonder if you can think back
to when we talked about like models that
represent reality often within the model
even when nothing is said explicitly
there are domain restrictions that exist
on your model there are constraints to
remember that okay so as an example
let's have a look at the very first
function x equals this
okay displacement right now if I were to
continue using this model what would the
parabola do if I kept on going to the
left
mmm now I quote to the model right well
it doesn't tell you what's happening to
the ball I guess you just hold it right
so really what it should do is just be
on the ground right but that's not what
this equation would do the equation
would say Oh apparently I have a ball
that borrowed up from underneath these
subdirector alien caverns and then came
up into the emerged out of the ground
right it's not what it does though right
so this model only exists between zero
and when it lands you can see I've done
the same thing because and stopped it
over here because I'm presuming you have
not thrown it so hard that when it comes
back to earth it like borrowers into the
ground okay it's not going to do that
the model stops okay so since this
placement only fits in this little range
here I've done the same thing for
velocity right you can see I've ended
here at the same spot I'm calling that
for now which is why you can see it
about halfway and then the same thing
for this I didn't write it but that ends
at four as well okay